>> Greg: YOU KNOW HIM AS THE
ANGRY WHITE MALE.
DID YOU KNOW HE'S ALSO COMEDIAN?
GIVE A BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
OUR DEAR FRIEND, TOM SHILLUE.
>> THANK YOU!
I LOVE YOU GUYS.
I LOVE A BIG CROWD WITH
UNCOVERED FACES.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE ARE IN A MOMENT OF EXTREME
CAUTION IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY WE GREW A
PAIR WE THOUGHT WE WERE SAFE.
WE PROBABLY WEREN'T.
REMEMBER THOSE RIDES IN THE
FAMILY CAR?
IN THE BACKSEAT, NO SEAT BELTS.
SEAT BELTS HIGHLY OPTIONAL IN
THE 1970s.
DAD TOOK A RIGHT AND YOU WOULD
SLIDE OVER TO THE LEFT.
TAKE A LEFT, SLIDE BACK.
IT WORKED.
WE WERE LESS SAFE, LESS
SENSITIVE IN THE 70s.
IF YOU WANTED TO KNOW ABOUT THE
SENSITIVITY LEVEL OF THE
1970s, LOOK AT THE
ADVERTISING.
LOOK AT THE COMMERCIALS.
WE HAVE THE FRITO BANDITO.
MOST POLITICALLY INCORRECT
SPOKESPERSON IN THE HISTORY OF
SALTED SNACKS.
A THREE AND A HALF FOOT TALL
MEXICAN THIEF.
HE WOULD STEAL YOUR FRITOS AND
EAT THEM WHILE YOU WATCHED.
HE WOULD PULL HIS SOMBRERO OVER
HIS EYES AND TAKE A NAP.
THEY WOULD NEVER GET AWAY WITH
THAT TODAY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE GUY
SUGGESTING THAT AT THE AD AGENCY
TODAY?
THEY WOULD BE LIKE OKAY.
YOUR CONCEPT, THE FRITO BEEN BA.
PHIL, YOU DON'T WORK HERE
ANYMORE.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO TO H.R. RIGHT
NOW.
ALL THE COMMERCIALS WERE
INSENSITIVE.
REMEMBER THE DETERGENT?
HOW DO YOU KEEP YOUR HUSBAND'S
SHIRTS SO CLEAN?
ANCIENT CHINESE SECRET.
SOME WERE VIOLENT.
REMEMBER THE HAWAIIAN PUNCH?
EVERY COMMERCIAL WAS THE SAME.
THERE WOULD BE KIDS ON THE
PLAYGROUND.
OUT OF NOWHERE, THIS HAWAIIAN
WOULD WALK IN AND PUNCH THE KIDS
DIRECTLY IN THE FACE.
IT WASN'T A FUN TAP.
HE WOULD CLOCK THE KIDS.
IT WAS AN UNCONSCIOUS CHILD ON
THE PLAYGROUND.
EVERYONE CELEBRATING.
HAWAIIAN PUNCH.
TIMMY IS IN A COMA.
THE JINGLES WERE POLITICALLY
INCORRECT.
THE HOT DOGS.
ARMOR HOT DOGS.
WHAT KIND OF KIDS EAT ARMOR
HOT DOGS?
FAT KIDS.
YEAH, FAT KIDS.
THEY LISTED ALL THE CHILDREN OF
THE WORLD, START WITH THE FAT
KIDS.
WAS THERE A DISCUSSION?
SHOULD WE START WITH THE FACT
KIDS?
DEFINITELY.
THAT'S THE CUSTOMER BASE.
SECURE THE FATTIES AND MOVE ON.
FAT KIDS, SKINNY KIDS, KIDS TO
CLIMB ON ROCKS, VERY SPECIFIC
DEMOGRAPHIC.
TOUGH KIDS, SISSY KIDS.
THEY SAID SISSY KIDS AND THEY
SHOWED SISSY KID BAWLING HIS
EYES OUT.
YOU'RE GOOD AT IT, CRYBABY.
EVEN KIDS WITH CHICKEN POX.
WOW.
THAT'S APPETIZING.
EVEN KIDS WITH CHICKEN POX.
LOOK, I DID NOT GO TO
COPYWRITING SCHOOL BUT I'M
PRETTY SURE RULE NUMBER ONE IS
DON'T ASSOCIATE YOUR PRODUCT
WITH THE COMMUNICABLE DISEASE.
YOU'RE GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH